act shocked
[Music]
a star is born tamara maury housley
shared the most adorable video of her
five-year-old daughter arya
showing off her acting skills and the
end result is enough to make anyone's
day
well you said that you wanted to be in a
movie with mommy right
yeah okay well
can you show me if you can listen
the talented toddler then showcased an
impressive full range of emotions
including her best happy and sad faces
[Music]
then came her shocked and angry faces
act shocked
[Music]
act mad
wow tamara captioned the cute clip
i just may have a little actress on my
hands she kept saying
mommy i want to be in a movie with you
and so we have been practicing
our acting i love hashtag my mini me
shocked
after the five-year-old completely
nailed her audition
tamara said what every aspiring actress
wants to hear
guess what you got the part yeah
and judging by our audience in the
comments section everyone was in
complete agreement that little miss arya
is going to be a star some would even
say she reminded fans of other talented
family members too
like tamara's younger brother taj maury
it's a beautiful thing one commenter
wrote
that was a smart guy shocked face indeed
she's adorable
back in october tamera revealed to e.t
that arya wants to be an actress one day
she wants to be on tv she kind of hinted
to me
she's five um i'm exploring
a little bit of it you know just to make
sure that this is something that she
really
you know she really wants to do um
and i'm gonna i obviously i have to
support her
you know 100 100 percent so who knows we
shall see
and the five-year-old ta is totally
obsessed with mama's old hit
tv show sister sister i was cleaning the
kitchen
and she was like mom mom mom let's sit
down and watch sister sister let's sit
down and watch
i was like mariah no no no just wait for
a second mommy
mommy has to do this mommy mommy has to
go work out mommy
no mommy mommy mommy i just want to sit
down and i want to watch the sister i go
okay
you you can watch this no i want to
watch sister sister with you i want you
to
i want to just sit down and watch the
sister i swear she knows how to find it
on her computer
she has her little little little ipad
and again you will hear sister
sister
never knew how much i'm like are you
watching sister sister she's like uh-huh
i like that knowing that your daughter
is such a fan
would you ever want to see her step into
that role she said she wants to be in
one of mommy's movies
so i the next generation of
tea and tamara campbell played by ariah
and
cairo in cairo
i'm gonna manifest that that would be so
dope
that would be so awesome